foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday well MPS return to Parliament
tomorrow after recess and number 10 will
be hoping to take back control of the
news agenda because the last week has
been dominated by an extraordinary round
that seems like it's been directly
lifted from the thick of it the covid-19
inquiry demanded access to unredacted
whatsapps which the government refused
to provide but just as they launched a
legal challenge to keep some messages
secret Boris Johnson decides to hand
everything over and circumvent the
cavern office a decision made purely out
of the goodness of his Hearts I'm sure
rather than to cause maximum trouble for
Rishi CNAC it does leave you thinking
though one Earth could be in those
whatsapps on the program tomorrow today
I should say can't get the days of the
week right uh first up this morning I'm
going to be talking to the immigration
Minister Robert generick
for labor we'll be talking to you the
shadow business secretary Jonathan
Reynolds
at the starts at the GMB Union annual
conference will speak to their General
Secretary Gary Smith
plus dramatically barred from running to
the Northeast mayor we'll also be
speaking to the current north of time
mayor Jamie Driscoll
[Music]
good morning welcome to the show today
now if you're wondering why a Claire
Watson isn't in our opening sequence
that's because we were expecting to have
it on the program today but
unfortunately she hasn't been very well
so we'll definitely get it booked in
another time uh soon now Rishi CNAC has
pitched his Premiership on the pledge to
stop the boats but let's be honest that
is easier said than done well tomorrow
the illegal migration Bill hits the
House of Lords and it aims to stop
people arriving in the UK on small boats
from claiming Asylum a few moments ago I
spoke to the immigration Minister Robert
Generac
thank you very much for being on the
program uh this morning so last July
Rishi CNAC laid out a 10-point plan to
tackle illegal migration how's that
going
well we've made a lot of progress in a
short period of time we've already
lented into really unique Landmark deals
with France which are seeing a big
increase in the number of interceptions
on the beaches 33 000 migrants were
stopped Crossing as a result of that
last year a 40 increase on the year
before we've entered into a gold
standard arrangement with Albania that
is seeing thousands of Albanian legal
migrants returned home and the numbers
Crossing from that country significantly
reducing we've just entered into an
agreement with Georgia we've entered
into one with Italy and on the domestic
front we've increased the amount of
illegal working visits like raids on car
washes and nail bars and so on by 50
percent this year alone all to make it
harder to operate in the UK If you're
either an illegal migrant or one of the
people smuggling gangs and just this
week I've been in North Africa in
countries like Tunisia and Algeria area
taking the fight to the people smuggling
gangs Upstream before people have even
got close to the UK okay we're
increasing the resources of Our National
Crime agency through operation and vigor
so that they have the resources to smash
the gangs and organized immigration
crime so on every front we're taking
action and we're starting to see the
results of that in the numbers crossing
the Channel I want to unpick some of
what you've said a little later in the
interview just to try and work out you
know exactly the progress that is being
made
But first you recently said in a speech
that people who arrive in the UK on
small boats are cannibalizing our
communities
what what do you mean by that well I
didn't say that what I said was that
they risk cannibalizing The Compassion
of the UK public because what we're
seeing with the small boats is a very
large number of mostly young men leaving
safe countries like France often having
passed through multiple safe countries
coming to the UK and then requiring
immense resource here to accommodate to
support and to integrate them what I
mean by the word cannibalizing though
why don't you choose that word is this
very eye-catching word well I think it's
the right it's the right terminology
that the illegal migration challenge the
small boats crisis is making it harder
for the UK to do what we really want
which is to support people who are
genuinely seeking the support of the
United States you're saying it's making
it harder for the UK to do what they
want but usually cannibalizing what did
you mean by cannibalizing because with
small boats you're finding that tens of
thousands of young men who are in a
place of safety who are predominantly
economic migrants are coming to the UK
putting overwhelming pressure on our
Asylum system and on the compassion
generosity of the British public and
making it then harder for us to support
people who genuinely need our help and
what we want to do as a government is
devote our finite resources to helping
families and those people who are in
Conflict zones by continuing to do
world-class resettlement schemes like
homes for Ukraine the Syrian and Afghan
scheme by doing our Global scheme that
works with the United Nations to take
people out of refugee camps and bring
them in a controlled manner to the UK if
you allow uncontrolled illegal migration
to escalate then I'm afraid the British
public will find it harder to support
people who genuinely need our help and
that is why we're taking the very robust
steps that we are to get this problem
under control so let's see how you are
getting the problem under control what's
the current backlog for Asylum claim
processing well there's over 150 000
cases in the backlog but we've made a
very clear pledge to eliminate the
Legacy backlog over the course of this
year we made that pledge at the end of
last year and the Prime Minister the
home section I put in place a robust
plan which is now working it's not
working there's a number of cases in the
Legacy fall let's have a look you know
Asylum applications are wasting a
decision like you're talking about
Legacy there most people just look at
the overall cases it might be one thing
that you're starting to bring the Legacy
down but if the overall numbers are
going up that's different you can see
there's been a small fall between 2020.
I think most people would look at this
and not think that this is a system
that's under control do you accept that
uh I think the system needs robust
reform and that's exactly what we're
setting out to do we are putting in
place processes to streamline the way
decisions are taken to simplify remove
all the bureaucracy that has crept up in
recent years to double the number of
case workers making the decisions over
the course of this year and that is
beginning to have results as you can see
on the screen and I'm confident that we
will eliminate the Legacy backlog but
the key thing to note here is that the
sustainable answer to this challenge is
to reduce the number of people crossing
in the first place I've just been to a
number of European countries
of cases but the way to stop this
problem is not to focus solely on the
symptoms of it but is to focus on the
cause and that's what I'm saying the
bill that we're taking through
Parliament if I may um the backloggers
one element of this another element is
the number of people who have been
removed from the UK
um 38 000 failed Asylum Seekers and
foreign criminals removed from the UK
last year that's the newest number on
record other than the pandemic years
well if you look at the stats for the
beginning of this year which is the
period after the Prime Minister the home
section I put in place our plan we're
actually seeing returns back to
pre-pandemic levels and we want them to
rise we've signed an agreement with
Albania which is absolute best in class
we signed number one now with Georgia
let's talk about Albania then shall we
because as you say so many people uh it
did make up quite a large proportion of
people arriving on small boats so how
many you made a big play of the returns
agreement you struck with Albania so how
many people who've arrived on small
boats have been returned to Albania uh
well thousands of albanians are
returning to Albania I just want to I
just want to split that because I know
that foreign criminals are part of these
numbers as well many of those have also
if we're just talking about originally
if we're just talking about people
arriving on small boats how many have
been returned to Albania well there are
hundreds of albens who've arrived on
small boats who have been placed on
those flights as a result of the
processes we put in place and the
agreements that we've reached with
Albania and you only have to look at
what's happening hundreds how many
people at this point I'm just trying to
get you well if you only have to look at
what's happening to the number of
albanians making this thing this is a
different point because the two are
related
specifically is to deter people from
coming in the first place and that is
succeeding if I may I'm specifically
asking about the number of albanians
who've arrived on small boats who have
been returned under the agreement to be
completely onto you I'm trying to get to
the bottom about whether you're trying
to Cloud these figures is by focusing on
foreign criminals who've been returned
to Albania or whether this deal that you
struck with Albania is actually working
well the the foreign offenders in most
cases are being returned under the
arrangement because what happens and
this is why we need to reform the system
is that even after serving a sentence in
our prisons an offender will then put in
an asylum came they may then also claim
to be a victim of modern slavery they
make spurious last minute uh claims and
appeals to frustrate our ability to
remove them and that's why we reach this
agreement with Albania and so that we
can remove them
it is right that we focus on foreign
National offenders you know of course we
want to remove people who have come
across on small boats but we also should
be getting people out of our prisons who
have committed serious crimes
yeah I don't think anyone is wrong to
allow those people to British Society I
don't think anyone's disputing that I'm
just trying to work out how effective
the Albania returns deal is of the
number of albanians who've arrived on
small boats how many have been returned
under this gold standard as you put her
agreement well I said hundreds have been
returned
what happened to the rest of them well
if you've got this returns agreement
that means they can just click your
fingers and get that it was relatively
early days have they just disappeared
it's relatively early days but also you
only have to look at the numbers now
attempting to cross what's happened to
the others what's happened to the other
albanians then are they in hotels or do
you not know where they are uh some of
them are being accommodated some have
returned home voluntarily and some may
well have absconded but that is
absolutely the reason why we're taking
this action so because why are there
still albanians in hotels in the UK
there are very few we're working through
those cases and removing them but what
you're getting to the nub of the
question here which is that our system
has become riddled with legal processes
which enable people to make spurious
last minute appeals even the Lord chief
justice recently made this uh Point
that's why we're putting in place the
illegal migration bill that cuts all of
this process out in the first place and
is based on the very simple principle
that if you come across in a small boat
you have no right to live or make a life
in the UK you'll either be returned home
swiftly to a safe country like Albania
or you'll be returned to a safe Third
Country like Rwanda and you won't be
able to use our legal system or misuse
our legal system in order to frustrate
your removal if we can do that we will
break the people smuggling gangs we will
deter people from Crossing in the first
place and with respect to Albania you
only have to compare the proportion of
those people crossing the channel in the
first quarter of last year to the first
quarter of this year to see that this
has been hugely effective in creating
the deterrent effect that we set out to
okay let's top up the covert inquiry
shall we and the government's launched a
legal challenge so it doesn't have to
hand over unredacted WhatsApp messages
to the covert inquiry what's it got tied
we want to hand over to the covert
inquiry absolutely anything that has
anything to do with covid-19 or the
purpose of the inquiry and that's the
right thing to do this is an important
inquiry and we want Lady Justice Hallett
and her team to have access to all the
information that they need where there
is a point of difference is that we
don't think that it's sensible or
reasonable to hand over documents or
messages that have nothing whatever to
do with covid-19 and I'm a former lawyer
I've been involved in Discovery requests
from courts in the past and the normal
way to do this is to set reasonable
parameters to request anything that is
related to the case
or in this situation the inquiry but not
to ask for things that are wholly
unrelated nothing was ever to do with
the inquiries to decide that if you hand
it over then they can decide what's
relevant as a lawyer having been
involved in in Discovery in the past
that's not common practice but it may
not be common practice but this is an
exceptional set of circles well I can't
think of any situation where a court
would ask for
documents or messages that have
absolutely nothing to do with the
purpose of the case or the inquiry I
mean for example things to do with a
civil servant or a leader politician's
private life
that are wholly unrelated but do not
trust the inquiry to decide what's
relevant well there's no question about
whether we trust the inquiry or not we
have the highest regard for Lady Justice
hallerton her team we're not asking for
special treatment for the government
what we're saying is that we should
uphold common legal practice which would
be applied in any civil case in the
British courts and should be applied to
this inquiry we think that's very
reasonable I hope that this can be
resolved indeed before it matter even
gets to court and we want to continue to
cooperate productively with Lady Justice
Hallett to resolve it Boris Johnson of
course bypassing the cabin offer to send
his whatsapps directly to the inquiry
why do you think he's doing that
well it's it's entirely up to the former
prime minister how he cooperates with
the inquiry if he wishes to send his uh
documents or WhatsApp messages to them
then he's he's at Liberty to do so I
think a letter has been sent from the
cabin office to him to say that as he is
using taxpayers funds to pay for his
lawyers then that funding has to be used
for appropriate purposes but he can
advance whatever arguments he wants to
and make whatever statements he wishes
in his witness statement to the inquiry
there's absolutely no sense that the
government will uh restrict what Boris
Johnson wants to say but if you use
taxpayers funds obviously you should
make sure you're using them
appropriately I mean some would say that
this comes down to the relationship
between ports Johnson and Richie sunac
maybe not the most helpful course of
action for the former prime minister to
take and allies of Boris Johnson have
told them on Sunday that they think the
number reason number 10 doesn't want to
share their messages is because it could
reveal what you see now it's plotting to
bring down Boris Johnson no as I say the
the issue here is a simple legal one
which is should you hand over material
to an Inquirer which has absolutely
nothing to do with covid-19 and that's a
long-standing practice in British courts
I think it's fair and reasonable that
that's applied to the inquiry as well
and I hope that we can resolve this with
Lady Justice Hallett very soon now you
famously wrote a piece back in 2019
backing Boris Johnson I think have a
look at it along with two faces who
might be quite familiar to our viewers
if you can sort of look in their Rishi
sunak Prime Minister Oliver Dowd and the
former prime minister
do you regret backing Boris Johnson no
it was the right decision at the time
the country was facing a very serious
challenge we needed to get brexit done
to end the paralysis that there was in
Parliament at the time and to stop the
labor party led by Jeremy corbyn from
taking over our country so I'm sure all
three of us fully support that decision
but look we have a great prime minister
today in British sunak he's getting on
with the challenges facing the country
and I fully support it I mean you all
look a bit more fresh-faced back then I
think before the sort of political
roller coaster that we've all been on uh
Richardson ex prime minister now of
Oliver darlin's Deputy Prime Minister
and when you keep backing the White
Horse Boris Johnson then Richie sunac
are you a bit disappointed not to be a
secretary of state
look I it's entirely up to the Prime
Minister who who he appoints to which
job I'm I've always taken on difficult
and challenging roles this is certainly
one of them but it's one that matters to
the public the public want to see us
secure our borders to stop the boats and
that's what I'm working very hard with
the Home Secretary with the prime
minister to deliver okay okay thank you
very much thank you
immigration Minister Robert generic uh
they're talking about how effective the
government's strategy is on tackling
illegal migration also saying that it
wouldn't be sensible or reasonable for
the government to hand over all
ministers messages that have nothing to
do with covid-19 to inquiry well you're
watching safety Ridge on Sunday up next
we're going to be talking to Jonathan
Reynolds uh the shadow business Minister
plus the GMB Union Leader Gary Smith as
well
um there we go and we'll also be talking
on the program later on to Jamie
Driscoll now he's the current north of
time mayor who was told that he couldn't
run to be the mayor of the north east by
labor we'll try and get to the bottom
about what really happened with Jamie
dress at briscoll
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this program just after 9 30 where we
can analyze some of those interviews
with our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates but Sam joins us uh now uh Sam
good to see you this morning what did
you make an interview with Robert
janwick
I think it reflects
um what I suspect is quite a growing
amount of nervousness about the small
boats issue inside number 10. Richie
sunac has made solving the boat stopping
the boats one of his big priorities and
him and his ministerial team like Robert
generic have been out many many times
including this morning to talk about it
but the key Point Sophie is that the
legislation is still in train in
Parliament in other words nothing has
actually happened yet and the fact that
Richie sunac has gone out to bat on this
issue so much has actually created the
perception a perception that I know
number 10 are worried about that they've
started to take action but in fact all
they're trying to do at the moment is
try to pass a law and what that means is
that for all ministers like Robert
generic talk about this issue nothing
yet has changed so this summer
potentially is going to be very
difficult there are still as the weather
gets warmer as the conditions get easier
going to be cross people crossing uh the
channel in those small boats and The
Limited action that's been taken so far
isn't really working I mean it was an
extraordinary section of that interview
where as you highlighted initially uh
Robert genrex is slightly obfuscated
when you're asking him about the
Albanian returns deal and then conceded
that only hundreds of people people have
been returned to actually came over on
small boats in the first place and that
the rest are in hotels or potentially
have absconded and and therein lies the
Rob it's an admission and you saw that
admission very starkly this morning
after careful questioning that even the
bits of the even the changes that they
have made are not making substantial
differences and there's no guarantee
that the main thing that they're trying
to do which is this major piece of
legislation as you said at the top of
the program uh heading back to the house
of Lords tomorrow or in the House of
Lords tomorrow is going to get through
unscathed we don't know how long this
legislation is going to be held up by
peers we don't know what kind of changes
peers are going to demand of MPS but we
do know is that everything that they
want is going to mean that lots of time
is it's going to take lots of time to
for the government to get what it wants
it doesn't look as if we're going to get
this legislation passed before the
summer it's not clear when the first
flight's back to Rwanda and it's not
clear that the measures taken so far are
particularly effective yeah I was quite
Keen to pick him up on the Albania stuff
because you know the government always
points to that deal as being completely
key to their strategy when it comes to
Illegal migration Best in Class is how
Robert generic described it and yet when
it comes to the numbers when you start
digging down into them it feels to me
like they're trying to basically sweep
that under the carpet because they're
frankly not as good as they hate they
are and Sam well I've got you I've got
to get your take on the ongoing what's
out drama it does feel like this is
something that the thick of it writers
went completely off the walls with
um what on Earth is going on and what do
you think the outcome of this is going
to be
but being completely honest one of the
things that's going on is that for the
uh rather like parents with kids in
school for the last eight days it's been
recess in the hazards of parliament
which means that MPS haven't been around
and what's interesting is that there's
been a vacuum that number 10 hasn't been
able to fill to be honest labor hasn't
been able to fill and so quite a lot of
it was dominated by this rather odd
story about the government trying to
stop some whatsapps being released to
The Cove inquiry I think the motivation
of what's going on from Boris Johnson's
point of view is pretty clear I think
what he wants to do is put his whatsapps
in the public domain and they're of
course in large part going to be
whatsapps with Richie sunac and people
in Rishi sunax government and I think he
knows that there'll be episodes like the
help out to eat out scheme that Richie
sunac pushed back in uh 2020 that maybe
in the cold like of day look unwise now
and actually end up harming him there'll
be other conversations that Rishi sunak
had with Boris Johnson that are in those
whatsapps that Johnson held over handed
over to the covert inquiry that Boris
Johnson knows again may not look so good
in the cold light of day but I do think
a bit just a tiny bit of me uh thinks
that
uh there is a need for some caution what
what we're talking about is at ministers
civil servants every single WhatsApp
potentially being handed over and if I'm
being honest Sophie I don't particularly
mind admitting if all of my whatsapps
were handed over it would be the most
enormous skit fire
um and I think that what's got what's
going on is because we've now got
government by WhatsApp people say all
sorts of things that potentially quite
unwise on WhatsApp some of which have
nothing to do with their work some of
which do and and because lines have been
blurred between personal and
professional by this use of WhatsApp
this has created a problem the answer is
probably to stop doing government by
WhatsApp it may take the most ferocious
amount of kind of pain endured by a
government with every single message
being put on display if that's what the
covert inquiry chair ends up doing or
they end up leaking uh for that to be
achieved because at the moment the
messiness of WhatsApp means that all
sorts of things public and private get
blurred when uh which is done in that
way uh thank you very much indeed sand
capes there Sam says it will be a skip
fight if his whatsapps were released
obviously there's nothing to be seen in
mind completely uh pure and Angelic as
you would expect well let's get the
latest now from labor as Parliament
returns this week we're joined by the
shadow business secretary Jonathan
Reynolds uh thank you for being on the
program this morning and so you've been
talking a lot about your green energy
plans today with claims that would
create up to half a million jobs in the
next seven years so how do you work that
figure out
oh good morning Sophie look this is the
biggest Economic Opportunity in a
generation and that is why it is so
integral to Labor's economic policy and
our plans for government so the kind of
jobs we're talking about first of all
that is everything from an expansion of
offshore wind to solar to new technology
in terms of things like tidal and Marine
technology but also making sure we're
going to drive electric vehicles we make
them here in the UK our green steel
policy to make sure the steel industry
can do the transition towards net zero
wherever you look there are
opportunities here other countries are
Desperately Seeking these and actually
are far ahead of us and we're blowing
this opportunity under this government
and that's why everything labor is
putting forward is about getting the
most of that getting the massive
potential benefits this country should
have flowing to it from this transition
NetZero is about jobs good jobs for
every part of the country
so this is all part of your green
Prosperity plan you want to invest 28
billion pounds a year in that so you
know apologies for my maths over seven
years that works out at around 196
billion pounds a 196 billion pounds so
suddenly half a million jobs over seven
years
doesn't actually sound that great
because that would be you know just
under 400 000 pounds per job what how
does that work out
so look at it in each component so for
instance the resources we've allocated
to the green steel transition is around
two billion pounds of Investments
required to do that gigafactories will
will gear up over time depending on how
quickly we can deploy those things but I
just want to be clear about something
this government themselves because of
the fact that we aren't making batteries
in the UK it would be existential for
the automotive industry this government
themselves will have to put some money
into this and those are negotiations
which I understand are ongoing but the
difference between us and then is that
with them they're not public about this
you can't you can't download you can't
read their industrial strategy you have
to have it explained to you that it even
exists now for us it's an explicit it's
making a slightly different point here
about your plans and look you're the
guys who people think are going to be
number 10 off the let's election so it's
right that we scrutinize your plans uh
not just the governments 28 billion
pounds a year under the green Prosperity
plan to create half a million jobs in
the next seven years some people would
say that is an awful lot of money to be
spending
well I think if you look at the don't
look at the overall headline figure look
at the individual components we're
putting forward whether that's
insulating columns which brings down
bills provides jobs and gives greater
energy security to the UK whether it's
making sure we've got a steel industry
in the UK I don't think we can be the
first major developed economy that has
no domestic steel industry I think if
you look at the strength of the
automotive sector in the UK it isn't
conceivable to me that we don't seek to
make sure we're making the next
generation of vehicles electric vehicles
here in the UK and fundamentally every
bit of public investment we're putting
forward is about leveraging in Greater
private investment that is the lesson
from what the Biden Administration has
done in the US I think the fact that the
UK has the lowest rate of business
investment in the G7 is a disgrace and
fixing that is not just about public
money it's about planning reform
regulatory reform fixing the skills
pipeline through the changes we'd make
to things like the apprenticeship let me
but it will require in some particular
cases and gigafactories for battery
production is a good example a degree of
public investment to do that but we also
know very clearly that the longer term
costs of not acting on Net Zero and
climate change will be greater than
doing what is required now but
fundamentally the difference between
ourselves and the conservative party is
about getting the good economic benefits
to the UK that should flow from that I
think people would agree with that
overall thing I think it's just the
question mark about the scale of what's
being invested uh and whether or not
it's worth it in when you look at the
number of jobs that will be created 28
billion pounds a year and obviously
without wanting to play Down the
importance of environmental projects you
know some might say when public finances
are tight shouldn't some of that
investment be spent on other capital
projects whether it's hospitals housing
schools not directly linked to the green
agenda what would you say to that
looks like that's done a lot and the
fact is many public services in this
country are in a state I mean there are
no Public Services working better today
than when the conservative party came to
power in 2010 but I have to say that if
you look at the root of that for me it
is the fact we are paying relatively
high levels of taxation by historical
levels because growth has been so low
over the last 13 years so I see fixing
the economy driving economic growth good
jobs in all parts of the country that's
not being an alternative or a competing
demand compared to funding Public
Services I've seen as being absolutely
essential to be able to provide the
funding for those Public Services over
the long term I mean we are an aging
Society our pensions bill goes up by
about six billion pounds a year in real
terms every year unless you've got an
economy that is growing at faster than
1.4 which is the average it's been since
the conservatives came back to Power
you're not going to be able to pay for
that so getting the economy fixed moving
in a more prosperous Direction becoming
one of the best performing economies in
the G7 rather than one of the worst
that's got to be integral to fixing all
the other problems in the country and
the big story around the world is about
clean energy it is about Net Zero it is
about the economic benefits that we need
to gain for the UK from following that
path and that's why it is the
centerpiece of our uh economic strategy
we'll be talking later on the show to
Gary Smith at the GMB Union he's pretty
unhappy with your party's plan to end
North Sea oil and gas licenses I mean if
you are all about jobs isn't that a bad
idea
well let's just take this through the
components of the argument so first of
all the existing oil and gas fields in
the North Sea will run up right until
2050. we're not talking about turning
those off or ending that we are against
further new licenses being granted and
that's because it won't do anything for
bills it won't do anything for energy
security it's not a long-term answer to
jobs and clearly it would be a climate
disaster and it requires a few vast
amounts of public money in the form of
subsidy and allowances to make these
fields economic and attractive now I
understand because I I live and
represent part of East Manchester here
where I'm doing this interview from
Manchester United a group in the
Northeast and the coal fields of county
jobs I understand in the past this
country has done economic transitions
very badly and I think Gary is
absolutely right to defend and
strengthen the arguments for his members
to make sure they've got the the
opportunities they need going forward
because these existing Fields will run
until 2050. no one is going to be losing
their jobs within there but we've got to
understand that the opportunity in front
of us the number of jobs created from
clean energy is far in excess of the
existing directly employed Workforce in
North Sea oil and gas so it's not some
sort of consolation price this is the
big prize this is the big chance to do
that and we'll work with Gary to make
sure finally this country gets his
transition well I know that I haven't
got long left uh with you before you
need to leave and there are another
important questions that I do want to
get to because the labor MPE Grant Davis
has been suspended from the labor party
after serious allegations of
unacceptable Behavior this was uncovered
by politicus Aggie chambra now Sky News
understands that the labor party also
whips office was made aware of the
allegations months ago but didn't take
action is that right
I don't know the answer to that question
what I can tell you is I've been part as
an NEC member of overhauling the labor
parties uh processes across a whole
range of disciplinary matters we've
tried and done a huge amount of work to
improve it to put Independence for any
kind of political considerations as part
of that and I would urge anyone to have
confidence in that process and come
forward of course we will always keep
that under review and try and make it as
effective as it needs to be and there's
always more work to do but I can I can
promise people we've done a great amount
of work to try and improve how we
respond to this as a political party I
think a big difference between ourselves
and the conservatives is when something
goes wrong with the labor MP every time
I see it we take immediate action to
suspend the Whip and fulfill the
processes that we put forward and do it
in the proper manner
I was really shocked by an interview
that I heard earlier this week with the
labor MP Charlotte Nichols she said that
when she was first elected in 2019 she
was given a list of 30 MPS to not accept
a drink from to not get in a car with to
effectively watch out for their behavior
30 MPS I mean I had to check that that
wasn't a typo
how bad are things in Westminster
well I'm horrified by a story like that
that anyone would would first of all
have to be told that or that that
sentiment would even exist the fact that
we have done such a significant amount
of work in the labor party to try and
make sure our processes are better than
they've been in the past reflects the
need to operate to the highest standards
possible and you know there are many
people
who are horrified by this and we're
trying to improve our process it feels
to me like you're talking about the
processes that have been improved the
processes can't have improved that much
if serious allegations you know I I'm
careful about what I say here serious
allegations about an MP have only come
to light because of the work of
journalists it's not coming to light
because of what your party is doing
talking to people within it finding out
what's going on what's the evidence that
any of these processes are actually
making any difference at all
I think they are and I think they are
the kind of process which can give
people confidence because it's an
attempt to take out what I think people
have felt in the past which is there may
be some sort of political considerations
given to disciplinary action when the
effects matters of this kind we've tried
to remove that now look so there's a lot
of work to do and I understand we always
have to keep that under review and try
and do it better to respond to cases and
make sure in each case we can say this
has been as robust as it needs to be but
we have tried and I think if you look at
the immediate action the labor party
takes when any Member of Parliament or
elected representative has allegations
against them and has fallen potentially
below the standard required of them if
you look at the Swift action we take I
think that is the right approach I think
we haven't seen that always in the past
particularly from other political
parties we're trying to get it right and
we're always going to work until we can
have the absolute confidence we've got
the system and the processes in place
that we need
okay now we've got Jamie Driscoll on the
show later who's been barred from
standing as labor candidate for the
Northeast mayor now his supporters say
that this is all part of factionalism in
the labor party effectively kirstan were
trying to purge the left what would you
say to that
and I would strongly disagree with that
the labor party is a very large
organization which bigger I think still
than every other political party in
terms of membership added together but
case number has changed the leg party
since he became leader and part of that
process is we have a due diligence
process in place and that's because
frankly in the past not every person
elected as a labor representative has
met the standard required of them and
specifically in a case where somebody
shares a platform with someone who
themselves has been expelled from the
labor party for their views are
anti-Semitism for opposing the turf
action that needed to happen that would
preclude them from being a labor
candidate going forward because when we
said we'd have zero tolerance of
anti-Semitism and we said we would tear
it out from its roots we were serious
about that and I know sometimes that
will cause the rabbits maybe not the
expedient political thing to do but we
are absolutely serious about sorting
this problem out key astronomers made
that absolutely clear and no one should
be surprised that we're sticking to our
word
okay thank you very much indeed Jonathan
Reynolds there speaking to us from the
labor party thank you
well we heard a little bit there about
the debate should we say going on
between the labor party and one of its
biggest supporters the Trade union GMB
which says it's time for an honest
debate about the effects of brexit as
well as disagreeing should we say with
the labor party's policy when it comes
to oil and gas developments well
speaking at the start of the GMB Union's
annual conference Gary Smith says that
politicians from all sides are afraid to
admit what impact leaving the EU has had
on the economy but we can speak to Gary
Smith now thank you very much for being
with us I know you were listening along
to that interview with Jonathan Reynolds
and you of course represent an awful lot
of workers in the energy sector what did
you make of his response when it comes
to blocking or North Sea oil and gas
licenses
our Obsession this week is not whether
the factional politics or indeed the
politics of the labor party my priority
is listening to our members this week
the care workers fighting for 15 pound
an hour the Amazon workers fighting to
get Union recognition at their sites
energy will form part of the debate but
I'm obsessed with our members and
looking after the interests our members
not about the policies of Labor and on
oil and gas quite simply I think they
would have been naive they've got it
wrong you know um we are critical
Friends of the labor party and uh I
think there's just a lack of
intellectual rigor and thinking about
where they've got to on oil and gas
they're focusing on what they think is
popular rather than doing the proper
thinking to understand what is right for
the country
I promise I will get on to some of the
things that you're talking about at the
beginning uh there I apologize for the
order I've decided to do my questions in
but I do just want to ask a little bit
more about the oil and gas you say labor
being naive why do you think they're
being naive
because their their policies are going
to trade a cliff edge with oil and gas
instruct extraction from the North Sea
it's not going to be up to labor to
decide about investment in the future of
the North Sea the I I feel that
investment is going to dry up more
quickly than it should we are in a
process of manage decline in the north
shame we should be working together on
that but there is a lot of oil and gas
in the North Sea and the Alternatives
facing the country are that we either
produce our own oil and gas take
responsibility for our own carbon
emissions or we are going to import more
oil and gas and I think workers in the
petrochemical sector in grangemouth in
the Humber and teaside in pembrokeshire
and Folly I think they are going to be
very worried with what labor saying and
as I say it's time for labor daily to
focus on doing the right thing rather
than what they think is the popular
thing and you know our members in the
energy sector and the construction
sector aren't stupid
we've been promised tens of thousands of
jobs and Renewables but the truth is
those jobs have been created anywhere
but the UK our Renewables infrastructure
is getting built in China and Indonesia
anywhere really but Britain
I mean labors today are saying that they
will create half a million jobs through
their green energy plans you're a bit
skeptical of that then
well I I welcome this initiative I think
you know there's 13 years of failure
from the Tory government they've got us
in the whole on energy let's be clear
about that but working people in
Aberdeen and Humber and teaside and all
those areas that depend on the
petrochemical industry and energy
intensive manufacturing companies around
the country they are going to be worried
about the message from labor and I just
have to be honest related about that
we've been promised that we would be the
Saudi Arabia of renewals we'd be
promised time and time again that the
Renewables industry is going to create
all these jobs and they simply haven't
emerged there is a huge Wind Farm off
Brighton here where was that produced
where was all the steel and the wind and
the wind turbines fabricated it wasn't
in the UK and that has been the sorry
story of the Renewables industry around
the country labor should be focusing on
a plan for our energy future rather than
talking about bands Anatole Sophie I do
you know I would like to hear a labor
politician now being very clear with the
Renewables industry that there'll be no
future developments for offshore auto
insurance until we actually get some
jobs and investment in a fabrication and
manufacturing jobs and working-class
communities because that's what they're
doing in America and I'd like to see
that replicated from labor
uh now a really interesting um points
that you make in the interviews so far
um you started off talking about the
priorities going into your conference in
Brighton and about pay in particular
we've of course seen lots of strikes in
the public sector
just how difficult are things for those
on low wages and how long do you think
this industrial action could go on for
as a result
we represent workers in both the public
and private sector and what I celebrate
because we'll never apologize for
workers standing up to defend their
standard of limit we celebrate the fact
that working people have come together
got organized under the union Banner to
campaign to defend their living
standards the Tories have got us into an
absolute whole economically inflation
going through the roof the economy is
stagnating and working people are saying
we are not picking up the tab for the
Tory crisis we celebrate that fact we
welcome that fact and we're going to
talk about it over the coming days in
Britain there'll be a tremendous energy
in this room the ambulance workers the
health workers the ones that Tory said
they wouldn't talk about to talk about
pay with but we forced them to talk
about pay and then I'll be speaking our
members in private care who's struggling
on you know earning pennies above the
minimum wage I'll be listening to them
about their demands for certain social
care and getting to 15 pound an hour for
a minimum wage there
you obviously have members taking strike
action in the public sector but you've
also represented people who've seen
deals been struck I'm thinking
particularly of ambulance workers for
example in the NHS
do you think it is now time for unions
to start seriously accepting pay deals
with the government
well it's not just about government it's
where any employer I mean what we do as
a union the reason we're annoying the
union and I understand it's about any
employer but I'm just specifically
asking about these public sector pay
deals for now if I may
well
we listen to our members I want the
minds are shaped by the priorities of
our members and it's not about the trade
unions moderating the demands it's a bit
the Tory part in moderating its behavior
in government and accepting that people
are struggling financially and people
want a decent pay raise you know we had
people who were on the front line of the
covet crisis and the uh the you know
these people want a decent pay raise and
absolutely deserve one
you were talking about Amazon workers of
course in ongoing dispute
do you think that as consumers we should
be shopping at Amazon
well Amazon the retail business is only
part of the company what concerns me is
that they provide a huge amount of
services to the public sector and if
they're not going to treat their workers
properly if they're not going to
recognize their employees rightful and
legitimate demand to have the GMB
recognized on their sites then there has
to be question marks about them getting
public sector contracts in future they
make a huge amount of their money from
what is almost at your a very powerful
position that they have are in providing
web services to the public sector and
that's going to have to be challenged as
well
now this morning the Observer on a
slightly different note you say that
politicians on all sides need to start
being honest about the effects of brexit
of course if you look at both parties uh
both labor and the conservatives they
say that the debates on brexit is over
they don't want to join the single
Market they don't want to join the
Customs Union
are you disappointed I guess by the
position of both labor and the
conservatives when it comes to brexit
Luke I think I travel all around the
country we've got members of length and
breadth of the UK and Ireland I
understand that you know brexit is not
going to be Revisited by the politicians
but there has to be an honest debate
about the impact that brexit has has had
it is part of the reason that we're
seeing the inflation that we've got
stuck in the economy it is having an
impact on investment in the UK and I
just think it needs to be on honesty
about that and looking forward to
policies around the future the defense
manufacturing and we talked about green
energy the UK is going to have to have
strong trading relationships with Europe
and indeed America and I think there's
going to have to be a reset of our
trading relationships with Europe and
America and we're going to have to
really start having that honest
conversations about the impact of brexit
on jobs and investment here in the UK
finally um Sky News has been reporting
this week on the latest developments at
Asda the owners of the supermarket are
going to buy their sister company EG
petrol forecourts but the GMB has spoken
out against the deal and why are you
against it
well we're concerned about the impact
this is going to have in terms of
competition and things like petrol
prices but a big worry is about the
amount of debt that is being heaped on
the Asda business and the long-term
implications that that's got for jobs in
the company and let's not forget we have
tens of thousands of equal pay cases
against Asda we think equal pay is going
to cost the company about 1.5 billion
pounds and given all the debt given this
pretty opaque ownership structure who's
going to be picking up the liabilities
for the money our women members Asda are
due
okay thank you very much uh indeed good
to speak to you from Brighton thank you
thank you
well that was a Gary Smith there of the
GMB with some pretty pointed uh words
should we say to the labor party when it
comes to their policy on oil and gas
doing quite a bit of Labor this week
because the next guest is all about
internal War should we say in labor as
well Labor's barred one of its elected
Regional Mayors from running for
re-election Jamie Driscoll who is the
north of time mayor since 2019 was told
of the decision on Friday evening I
should clarify this is not to be
re-elected as the north Italian uh mayor
this is to run for the new position of
the north east uh mayor thank you very
much for being with us so how did you
find out that you were unable to run for
election
hey Sophie good morning um I got an
email an email said thank you for
applying
um you are unsuccessful to be taken
forward as a candidate
uh so yeah um you know I've been there
since 2019 as you said
um this so the area I cover is expanding
it will bring in other parts we'll be
covering the wider Northeast
um I've delivered thousands of jobs I've
built affordable homes
um I've implemented a grin New Deal
we're cycling child poverty across 90
schools in the region and expanding that
so when it comes to what the labor party
needs to project to win elections which
is economic competence I've got a
fantastic track record and for members
not to be allowed the choice
of putting me forward as the labor
representative is is frankly shocking
and I've had so much support from right
across the political Spectrum so what I
want is for for Kieran the labor party
to do nothing more than give members the
choice of choosing me as their candidate
so you've got the email uh saying that
your application has been unsuccessful
surely you must have known before that
that this was going to happen
um well no you can't know till you get
the email because because that's the the
decision being told
um so you go through a process you talk
to the NEC panel
um and we said look there's no issue
with your competence there is no issue
with anti-Semitism that we're very very
clear about that and they said it's an
issue that because you spoke to Ken
Loach
um that may causes electoral damage in
future was their argument I said if you
think Labor's been losing election
because I spoke to Ken Loach it was a
really successful filmmaker and he just
produced a film in the Northeast
and I was asked as part of the
celebrations for the live theater
would you have a conversation with Ken
Loach so yeah of course if it's just
about his films which it was and that
was it yes that's one hour of my last
four years as mayor so they're not let
members have the choice and make that
decision of do they want me to be their
candidate to me seems wholly
disproportionate if that is the reason
but that's not the reason they don't
they don't give the reasons
I mean labor say that that was the
reason that you were not allowed to run
because as you say you did share a
platform with Ken loach
you will say that it was just about the
films that he made but at the same time
this is somebody who's been you know
expelled from the party and I do just
want to read you some of the things that
can Loach has said because when he was
asked uh if a discuss in a discussion
about whether or not the Holocaust
happened was unacceptable he said that
history is for all of us to discuss the
founding the state of Israel for example
based on ethnic cleansing is there for
us all to discuss the role of Israel now
is there for us all to discuss so don't
transubert that with false stories of
anti-Semitism that was when he was asked
whether or not a discussion on whether
the Holocaust happened would be
acceptable he's also said that the
actions of the state of Israel make
increasing anti-Semitism understandable
he said if there has been a rise I'm not
surprised in fact it's perfectly
understandable because Israel feeds
feelings of anti-semitism
I mean surely you can see why sharing a
platform with kenloch may be problematic
if no if you want to ask Ken about his
views then do that I'm not a
spokesperson for Ken Loach
um and let's be really clear
um that my combined Authority Under My
leadership has adopted the I ihra
definition of anti-semitism and
references the examples I've been on
Jewish labor movement
um training
um I work very closely with the Jewish
Leadership Council visit the synagogues
in my region so this is an entirely
separate issue about 10 loach's issues
you need to take a quick and lunch I'm
not a spokesperson
um but he's produced that there's only
been three feature films set in the
Northeast in a couple of decades I'm
Daniel Blake sorry we missed you and now
the old oak and so it is a big cultural
significant issue for the Northeast and
to talk to him about films I think is
entirely Justified I share platforms
with all sorts of people a couple of
weeks ago I was on the platform with Ben
hugeon that does not mean I endorse the
Tories economic policies
at the same time so you don't regret
sharing a platform with kennel H then
um I've regret this entire episode now
the whole thing's blown up and now labor
members are not getting the opportunity
you don't think it was wrong of you to
share a platform with Ken loach
and I think the issues of speaking to
somebody about something entirely
different from a controversial issue
um and you know my understanding is that
he's made all sorts of clarifications
and he's not a holocaust tonight I think
he wrote a letter to the New York Times
explicitly saying that the Holocaust was
a real event which of course it was so I
honestly Sophie I think we've got to get
the proportionality here what the public
wants from their politicians is to get
on with things and deliver things and
not to engage in culture wars
cancel culture or anything like that I
actually think that's electorally
damaging
I guess some people might say that
you know when
issues of anti-Semitism within the labor
party led to a big distrust by the
Jewish Community kirstan is trying to
rebuild that trust that you sharing a
platform with Ken Loach who you know
I've read out some of the things that he
said when it comes to anti-Semitism when
it comes to Israel and the Holocaust
and you don't really think that is
problematic you think it's right that
you talk to him about the films I think
we should let the members make that
decision
let's trust the labor party members to
say do we think that Jamie's done a good
job as Matt do we think he'd win as an
election do we think actually is an
electoral asset and I would think you
would find that Yes actually would be
the result there's a pattern of behavior
here I think that
people who support renationalization of
the utilities who support stronger
workers rights as being excluded at lots
of stages in the labor party whether
that's standing as MPS whether that's
frequently as counselors people have
been deselected I've spoken to Mayors
and peace people who are ministers in
the new labor administrations all of
whom are really worried The Sword of
Damocles is hanging above them and
they're going to be next
so you think this is about factualism in
the labor party effectively clear storm
of purging the left
I think there's a big issue if you look
at what's happened
um if you look at you know some of the
things that have happened to me recently
um as a sitting there I should
automatically be allowed to contact
members I was asking for this for about
two years and got um it finally got an
email from the regional director saying
because you are a potential candidate in
a future election we can't give you it
everybody's a potential candidate I've
had labor party staff ringing this is
anything way before I spoke to Ken about
films saying um you must disinvite Jamie
because there may be an event coming up
um where there's going to be a selection
for the labor candidate you know this is
um there is a big issue here
um about democracy about should people
be like that's how we do elections in a
civilized country isn't it Sophie you
know you let people decide do they want
their candidate why should you bar
someone on the basis of that decision
and I guess you know just come back to
they would say that the barring is
because of their huge concerns about
taking a red line when it comes to
anti-Semitism and sharing platforms with
people uh in regards to that as well I
mean have you read the ehrc report into
anti-Semitism in the labor party yeah
on the platform so you know if you
um I've done your way the question was
about the ehrc report into anti-Semitism
if you read the report
so not the full report no I haven't um I
haven't read the full forward report
either
um yeah you've perhaps got to bear in
mind I'm not an opposition politician
I'm a labor mayor in power delivering my
focus is on doing good things for the
people in our region not internal labor
party management I'm not involved in
that in any sense at all really
um so you know from from 60 70 hours a
week I'm delivering jobs I'm building
homes I'm negotiating to get more money
in the region currently negotiating with
Pension funds to get an extra two
billion pounds of investment for us so
the labor party management stuff but
here's the kicker the labor party's
official position on Ken Loach is we do
not comment you know so you ask you you
check for clarification what's what's
the appropriate procedure and there
isn't one so how on Earth are you
supposed to avoid sharing a platform
with someone that later turns out should
be controversial
um this the general public will look at
this and think it's crazy they're
successful mayor that has huge
cross-party support
and labor members aren't even allowed
the choice to vote for him that's crazy
so what are your next steps are there
any sort of appeals process you're going
to run for another position
um well um I am still a labor party
member I'm still at mayor for the next
11 months no matter what happens
um I would like Kia to have a look at
this
um I would like him to say look let's
let the members decide uh my Trade union
is backing they've got huge support from
across the party
um I I've had a look at the legal routes
it's not all clear what they are
um and then you know I really do think
that just let members choose who they
want as their candidates that's how
democracy works and I honestly think of
yourself actually in a two-party system
if you're going to ban people who are
promoting socialist views from
participating in that that is really
quite anti-democratic
okay thank you very much for being on
the program indeed Jamie Driscoll there
or busy uh show today and things of
course are really gonna be cranking up
next week as Parliament returns after
recess well that's it this week's safe
Ridge on Sunday in a moment though after
the break we're gonna be running through
today's interviews seeing what we
learned I'll be joined by our Deputy
political editor Sam coats thanks for
joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on the program try and work out what we
learned have a bit of an analysis what
it means for the week ahead the
government guest was Robert generic the
immigration Minister and there's going
to be lots on immigration this week
because Parliament is returning from
Recess a House of Lords they're going to
be having their say on the illegal
migration bill that bill that says it
will be illegal for anyone to claim
Asylum if they entered the UK on a small
boat and we're expecting Russia's United
to be really leaning into this issue as
one of the ones that he thinks might be
able to bring him election Victory if he
could if there is a landing zone for
that next year so we did lots about on
the program with Robert generic I was
particularly Keen to get into the weeds
of it though to try and really unpick
the headlines if you like because it
feels to me that the government spends
an awful lot of time uh talking big when
it comes to migration Rwanda plans
hotels barges but if you actually if you
look at the numbers of what they're
actually doing it feels shall we say
it's slightly more limited and so I was
asking Robert generic specifically about
the deal with Albania the returns
agreement with Albania that is that they
refer to as the Best in Class how
effective is that returns agreement
let's have a listen
there are hundreds of albens who've
arrived on small boats who have been
placed on those flights as a result of
the processes we put in place and the
agreements that we've reached with
Albania and you only have to look at
what's happening
at this point I'm just trying to get you
well if you only have to look at what's
happening to the number of albanians
making this thing this is a different
point because the two are related
is to deter people from coming in the
first place and that is succeeding if I
may I'm specifically asking about the
number of albanians have arrived on
small boats who have been returned under
the agreement to be completely onto you
I'm trying to get to the bottom but
whether you're trying to Cloud these
figures by focusing on foreign criminals
who could return to Albania or whether
this deal that you start with Albania is
actually well the the foreign offenders
in most cases are being returned under
the arrangement because what happens and
this is why we need to reform this
system is that even after serving a
sentence in our prisons an offender will
then put in an asylum came they may then
also claim to be a victim of modern
slavery they make spurious last minute
claims and appeals to frustrate our
ability to remove them
uh Robert John Rick there well during
Tate were joined as usual by adaptive so
some codes to analyze at some of the
interviews
we got there in the end didn't we at
hundreds of albanians it's not quite the
kind of gold plated deal that I was
perhaps expecting
now and and I thought what the interview
highlighted really well was the way that
ministers kind of dance around different
types of Statistics in order to muddy
the picture uh and you managed to cut
through that but um essentially there
are three different things there's the
overall net migration figure the number
of people seeking uh uh to come and live
and work in the United Kingdom and
that's at a record high and whenever you
seem to talk about that then Minister
switched to talking about illegal
migration now uh that is in the Public's
Consciousness often an issue to do with
small boats but when you raise issues of
small boats then ministers jump and talk
about the kind of um uh criminal uh
illegal migrants and the returns to do
with them and that that's the kind of
that's what you saw Robert generic doing
this morning because the truth is that
returning economic migrants who came
across the channel in small boats well
that just hasn't been going very well
and you have a minister uh in front of
you this morning admitting that some of
them are still in hotels and some of
them have absconded
um and I think that's because uh for all
the
um publicity around the Albania returns
deal actually using that to deal with
the small boats issue is very hard
this is a particular importance right
now today tomorrow I I mean it could be
as soon as tomorrow that the Prime
Minister announces a new returns
agreement or a new deal rather uh with
Bulgaria now that's the country uh on
the Turkish border uh on the Eastern
flank of the European Union uh where I
think we're going to hear details of a
new deal very very imminently to try and
as it were stop people coming over from
Turkey uh and potentially making their
way to the United Kingdom
um of course there was that devastating
earthquake in Turkey in February and
there are some home office officials who
think that that uh tragedy could mean
that there's another wave of people
seeking uh to come to the United Kingdom
there'll be a debate over whether or not
they're right to do so there'll be a
debate over whether or not uh we can
house them there'll be a debate about
whether or not other countries in the
united in the European Union should take
those people but we're about to have the
debate sort of that we've been having
about Albania uh over a deal with
Bulgaria and it's going to kick off
maybe as soon as soon as tomorrow
because
it's really really hard to get the
policy on small boats right even where
there is this a returns agreement with
Albania it's clearly difficult to return
people through it that's why
you've got people sitting in hotels and
that's not even mentioning the people
who've just absconded and they can't
find out where they are and this is a
country that we've managed to get a
returns agreement with and I guess it
just you wondering
you know
you see like standing at a Podium stop
stop the small boats Underneath Him is
this really a sensible pledge for the
government to make
well I think it's a probably a pledge
that they felt that they needed to make
if they hadn't made it there would be
enormous pressure from back benches it's
clearly an issue that Royals member of
members of the of the public and
immigration has played such a big role
in our politics really for the last 20
years I can remember it uh featuring him
back then illegal Asylum Seekers back in
the 2005 general election Tony Blair
versus Michael Howard it is a
conversation that has run through our
politics definitely run through the
brexit debate the the problem is I think
the question is Sophie did Richie sooner
make an achievable promise uh because
even when he was Downing Street what
stop the stop the boats actually means
which is the thing that he pledged at
the beginning of the year that he was
going to do they stopped short of saying
that means no no people coming across
the channel whatsoever so what it is how
you achieve it what it means in practice
what it looks like I think at the point
at which they did none of that was quite
clear and now they're having to race to
as it were satisfy a promise that at the
moment that Rishi sunak said that he was
going to do it he he didn't know what he
was doing or how he would do it
um the debate as you say on immigration
is going to run on and on and certainly
more this week as well and but I do just
want to talk a little bit more with Sam
but we'll play the grab uh first from
Roger Robert Emerick on the other story
that's been rumbling on this week which
is that extraordinary ongoing row about
Boris Johnson's whatsapps uh what the
covert inquiry has demanded what the
cabinet office is saying is unacceptable
and I did ask Robert generig is it
appropriate for the inquiry to be asking
for unredacted WhatsApp messages from
members of the government let's have a
listen to his answer
the normal way to do this is to set
reasonable parameters to request
anything that is related to the case
or in this situation the inquiry but not
to ask for things that are wholly
unrelated nothing whatever to do with
the inquiries to decide that if you hand
it over then they can decide what's
relevant as a lawyer having been
involved in in Discovery in the past
that's not common practice it may not be
common practice but this is an
exceptional set of circles well I can't
think of any situation where a court
would ask for
documents or messages that have
absolutely nothing to do with the
purpose of the case or the inquiry I
mean for example things to do with a
civil servant or Anita politician's
private life
well that's see what generic line let's
get a Sam again shall we
were talking about this earlier weren't
we and look I think there will be a
certain amount of sympathy for people
who say look you shouldn't have to give
over every single WhatsApp you've ever
sent whether that's private jokes with a
colleague whether it's trying to
organize your daughter's swimming
lessons you know we there is a degree of
sense sympathy on that I guess what some
people would say is
surely it's for the inquiry to decide
what's relevant or not not the cabin
office
absolutely Sophie and and it was really
interesting in your interview with
Robert generic when you said because
like privately what you get is the worry
amongst ministers amongst officials that
that what might happen is if they hand
over every single WhatsApp message then
some of them might accidentally
accidentally leak whoops and they are
very worried about that happening so
even if uh the chair of the covert
inquiry only decides to release a few
that are obviously relevant there will
be some people who end up uh losing out
because others in the inquiry perhaps
are less trustworthy now I have to say I
I've watched a fair few inquiries I have
not seen
um confidential messages leaked from
inquiry staff in the way that some are
alleging so it seems to me that that's a
little bit um a little bit far-fetched
and a bit of a sort of uh ridiculous
argument uh Robert generick in the
interview with you was making the case
no of course we trust
um uh the the inquiry to handle
materials sensibly but the big problem
here is that they shouldn't be doing
government on WhatsApp you know
government or Whatsapp is like anybody
else's WhatsApp uh sometimes the right
people are in the group sometimes the
wrong people in the group sometimes it's
all done a bit informally sometimes the
conclusion isn't really clear but you've
got a whole Civil Service waiting to
implement what decisions are made in
government be that on WhatsApp or
however else so perhaps the best thing
Sophie is you know in the end if the
court of appeal decides uh that
whatsapps have to be handed over and
more of the disclosures are made than
ministers would like then we just come
to the conclusion that that's tough they
have to endure the pain and just learn
the lesson not to do government by
WhatsApp again it does really feel like
that is the lesson doesn't it I guess
like I remember kind of like a few years
ago when what's that felt relatively new
people were using it in Westminster in a
way that we hadn't been used to it felt
kind of secret like private almost
didn't it like you know you heard this
thing called encrypted messages does
that mean that no one's ever going to be
able to access them but of course if
there is a written record of things then
it's just like any other written record
Runners emails or or a paper that's put
in your red box
foreign
and quite frankly Sophie if screen grabs
of whatsapps weren't able to be shared
uh I'd be if not quite out of a job then
certainly having less fun uh because it
is that ease with which you can share uh
screen grabs of whatsapps that is
proving so deadly uh for politicians of
all the strides I mean frankly uh it's
the danger when you use WhatsApp um but
it's a danger that every single
politician knows yet they still write
silly things on it it was just what 10
days ago that here at Sky News we did
the uh published the exchange of Tory
MPS talking about this covert inquiry
and whether things should be disclosed
with one uh labor and one Tory MP Jackie
Dole price saying that people briefing
against the Prime Minister were in
danger of create turning the Tory party
into a skit fire you had that Infamous
exchange with Andrea Jenkins who
suggested that figures like Simon Burns
were uh letting down the conservative
party uh Simon Hall sorry we're letting
down the uh conservative party and and
so people do write incredibly aggressive
things probably intended to be in
private on WhatsApp despite another part
of their brain presumably knowing about
the dangers I I I think there's a little
bit of a bigger point though um if I may
um I I think that we've spent seven days
discussing at different parts of the
media discussing this issue of whatsapps
and and for me this is a symptomatic of
something that that actually neither the
government nor the labor party haven't
have had anything big to say over the
last week if I'm being completely honest
I find that this whole WhatsApp
discussion you know quite tedious
there's a there's a small point of
principle here and there's going to be
an interesting outcome but the way that
Westminster has obsessed over the
entrails of this um uh uh rather turgid
debate has um has probably put quite a
lot of people off politics in the last
uh six or seven days and and but I think
that that's not necessary certainly even
the thought of journalists I think
that's the full of there not being
anybody in either party who sought to
set the agenda over the recess period
because they're a massive massive things
going on big tensions inside government
big decisions to be made and big
problems not least with inflation uh the
cost of borrowing and all of those kinds
of things that are getting less
attention because both of the big
parties don't shy away from difficult
issues and prefer to kind of pick over
the entrails of something that in the
scheme of things is relatively trivial
but there's one person who's been
seizing control of the news agenda over
the last week and that is Boris Johnson
he's done it pretty successfully I have
to say sam thanks very much for your
analysis we'll have more from Sam in a
few moments plus some of our other
interviews from the show don't go
anywhere
[Music]
we've actually had over a dozen
drownings in the last two weeks which is
coincided with the weather starting to
warm up and our concern is that as more
people want to get out and about as much
people want to enjoy the weather that
more young men especially are going to
lose their life to Drowning so our
message is is really really clear um
people's perception of their ability and
swimming ability that they might have
collected in a swimming pool which is
warm and regulating has lifeguards in
the pool side it doesn't translate
necessarily into cold Open Water where
there are lots of dangers and Hazards so
unless you're well supervised by a
lifeguard we really do urge people not
to be getting into the water especially
if they're not used to Cold Water
Swimming especially when it's really hot
days people obviously do want to call
off but we believe it's a and a
difference of people's perception of
their ability to swim Outdoors the issue
issue with inland waterways is they're
so freely accessible and there isn't
Live card cover actually at the coast we
actually see less drownings every year
because we know families are heading to
the beach they go into the red and
yellow flags where there's lifeguards
there to keep them safe but there is a
real issue in land where people have
free access to lakes and rivers and they
feel that they've got the ability to
swim in them and we see it time and time
again every year and that isn't the case
I think local authorities have in the
past tried to restrict access to certain
waterways um my experience tells me that
people will try and get access to those
anyway
um our work over the last few years has
actually been to try and work with local
authorities and local Council especially
to try and set up safe swimming zones
that they can be supervised so there's
lots of waterways now in the UK we've
seen the emergence of Open Water
Swimming venues and aqua Park sites that
are more freely less accessible to local
people where they can go and enjoy the
water and be safe and supervised so we
believe it's a it's a position of trying
to get people to the right area where
they can be supervised instead of
closing them up because we have seen in
the past unfortunately that just doesn't
work
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to Safe Ridge on Sunday the
take where we take you back through some
analysis of the mornings interviews well
on the program this morning we spoke to
Jamie Driscoll who's the current serving
north of time there he's been barred
from labor for running for the new
Northeast mayor of the party now he is
pretty upset about that labor have said
that the reason for that is because he
appeared on stage with the film director
Ken Loach she was expelled from labor in
2021 over comments he made about
anti-Semitism we'll talk to Sam in a
minute about this but just listen what
Mr Driscoll had to say when I read out
some of the views of Ken Loach and asked
why he shared a platform with a film
director
now if you want to ask Ken about his
views then do that I'm not a
spokesperson for Ken Loach
um and let's be really clear
um that my combined Authority Under My
leadership has adopted the I ihra
definition of anti-semitism and
references the examples I've been on
Jewish labor movement
um training
um I work very closely with the Jewish
Leadership Council visit synagogues in
my region so this is an entirely
separate issue about 10 loach's issues
you need to take a look at Lowes I'm not
a spokesperson
um but he's produced that there's only
been three feature films set in the
Northeast in a couple of decades I
Daniel Blake sorry we missed you and now
the old oak and so it is a big cultural
significant issue for the Northeast and
to talk to him about films I think is
entirely Justified I share platforms
with all sorts of people a couple of
weeks ago I was on the platform with Ben
huchen that does not mean I endorse the
Tories economic policies
So Jamie Driscoll there really I guess
being very defensive about some of those
sharing a platform with Ken Loach he
didn't say it was the wrong thing to do
he was explaining why he found it was
the right thing to do I also ask him
what he's considering in response being
banned from running for re-election
now I've had to look at the legal routes
it's not all clear what they are
um and then you know I really do think
that just let members choose who they
want as their candidates that's how
democracy works and I honestly think
here Sophie actually in a two-party
system if you're going to ban people who
are promoting socialist views from
participating in that that is really
quite anti-democratic
anti-democratic uh according to uh Jamie
Driscoll well let's bring some coats in
there
um I wasn't sure what tone Jamie
Driscoll would take in this interview
but he was very very strong in his
defense he said it was anti-democratic
from being uh that he was not allowed to
run for this new position he didn't
express any regrets about sharing a
platform with Ken Loach I mean he was
pretty Unapologetic
um yeah and it all touches quite a an
important deeper debate inside the labor
party about uh the way that uh kierstama
is approaching the left but but just on
the on the main point of the issue I
mean you can see why labor HQ don't want
Jamie Driscoll as Northeast mayor no
because necessarily just for the
incident with Ken Loach but a complete
failure of political antennae
look so if it doesn't it doesn't take
somebody Deep In The Weeds of
Westminster to know that kirstama's
singular Focus after coming in
post-jeremy corbyn was to deal with the
anti-Semitism semitism issue he was at
always was going to do that quite
robustly and he has picked this out
marked this out as a territory on which
he is going to fight and fight hard and
push quite aggressively to expunge what
he felt was the stain of anti-Semitism
on the labor party so Jamie Driscoll
should have known that this was a
massive risk Ken Loach his name has come
up uh be he renowned filmmaker or not in
the different views exist but he should
have known uh where Ken Loach sat with
labor HQ what they thought of him and
the dangers of doing this even if you
know if you go and ask somebody what
your official position is on the guy
they say they don't have one you should
just be able to see from space what
might happen if you associate yourself
with people like Jamie Driscoll with the
like Ken lights and when you read out
those quotes from Ken Loach about his
views about the Holocaust about his
views about Israel rather than go
they're revolting they're disgusting and
completely distanced myself that that is
not acceptable to say uh in the Modern
Age Jamie Johnson says I'm not a
spokesman for Ken Loach so I think for
those two things perhaps you can
understand some of the thinking down in
labor HQ
uh yeah I certainly can and like you say
it does feel doesn't it like it's a
battle that Kirsten was actually willing
uh to have yes you've had people like
John McDonald at coming out saying that
they think it's outrageous that Jamie
Driscoll hasn't been allowed to stand uh
but I guess
if the strategy is all about trying to
have a red line or anti-Semitism and
also distancing himself from Jeremy
corbyn you could say job done uh Sam
we'll have more from you in just a
moment because I do want to play a
couple of other Clips this morning
because this morning we spoke with Gary
Smith who's the German Secretary of the
GMB it's the start of their annual
conference in Brighton now there's a
round going on between labor on the GMB
about whether or not new oil and gas
projects should be banned in the North
Sea and you only have to listen to what
Gary Smith had to say about that to
realize the kind of depth I guess of
some of that disagreement
I'm obsessed with our members and
looking after the interstellar members
more about the policies of Labor and all
the oil and gas quite simply I think
labor have been naive they've got it
wrong you know um we are critical
Friends of the labor party and uh I
think there's just a lack of
intellectual rigor and thinking about
where they've got to on oil and gas
they're focusing on what they think is
popular rather than doing the proper
thinking to understand what is right for
the country
a lack of intellectual rigor and
thinking according to uh Gary Smith well
this is what Jonathan Reynolds a shadow
business secretary had to say
I understand in the past this country
has done economic transitions very badly
and I think Gary is absolutely right to
defend and strengthen the arguments for
his members to make sure they've got the
the opportunities they need going
forward because these existing Fields
will run until 2050 no one is going to
be losing their jobs within there but
we've got to understand that the
opportunity in front of us the number of
jobs created from clean energy is far in
excess of the existing directly employed
Workforce in North Sea oil and gas
well that was the round between the two
of them let's bring in Sam I mean wow a
lack of intellectual rigor and thinking
he said the head of the GMB Union said
labor was being naive when it comes to
the North Sea oil and gas I mean it was
he was pretty outspoken
yes Gary Smith he's a important figure
in the labor movement and uh he feels
this issue very strongly because he
represents tens of thousand people in
this sector but where his argument gets
quite difficult for the labor party is
that
um he reeled off lots of examples where
renewable projects that Britain uses
were actually manufactured overseas
China India elsewhere where the cost of
Labor is cheaper and this is the fear
right you can't have uh you can't
subcontract the production of North Sea
oil to another country uh you're going
to end up probably using largely uh UK
workers but that's not the case if you
need to make wind turbines if you need
to manufacture other components for the
transition to Net Zero they can be done
anywhere around the world and it's that
offshoring that Gary Smith is saying
it's quite interesting from Jonathan
Reynolds he he was running a slightly
less combative more nuanced line he was
saying that there will be oil and gas
used by the UK up until 2050 they're
only looking to stop new projects not
shut down the existing ones but of
course Gary Smith's argument the gmb's
argument is yes but if you start to wind
down the entire sector then businesses
will stop boring in the money start
closing down things prematurely there
might be gas in the ground but it's not
economically viable to get it out of the
ground if companies are no longer
investing because they know that there's
no future in the oil and gas sector uh
off the off the UK Shore and that we
could end up prematurely and
unnecessarily losing jobs I think there
is a concern I mean the labor party that
some of their green strategies there are
significant 25 billion pound but plus
borrowing plan to kick-start Green jobs
uh isn't well enough grounded well
enough grounded by the climate change
Shadow secretary Ed miliband in what's
economically viable and real in order to
convince voters and actually work in
government so I think when it comes to
Green questions that's an area that
kirstama probably needs to convince his
own side on a little bit more before he
even gets to arguing with the country it
does really feel doesn't it like there
is at that question mark over the green
policies and the value of money that it
brings Sam thank you very much indeed we
are out of time that is it from safe
Ridge and Sunday the take this morning
thank you very much for joining us this
Sunday see you next week
foreign
[Music]